how to find an angel investor so I got a
great question from one of my Google+
viewers bagus love you guys Baggett's
wrote in to ask I want to ask you how to
get investors who are willing to fund my
efforts in the field of fruit juice
franchises and how to connect with angel
investors so this is a great question
it's hard to answer in a couple minutes
I have an entire zuga guide on finding
angel investors that you can check out
but but I'll do my best a thing with
angel investors okay
most angel investors don't say hey I'm
an angel investor coming right to me
because it'd be bombarded with people
giving them pitches right and most
angels are not professional investors
meaning they don't do this full-time
most angels are what we call an industry
DDI
dentists are doctors with disposable
income or their wealthy professionals or
they're they may be lawyers Navy
accountants they may be successful
entrepreneurs they have a day job they
have something that they do and they
like to invest in companies on the side
the way my dentists described it to me
was he has a really boring life
nothing's a dentist and he likes to live
vicariously through his investments so
he likes me to tell his friends aren't
just invested in this this startup
that's doing this great thing in health
care or whatever it is in fruit juice
but you wouldn't have the guts to do it
himself so he wants to have that passion
and excitement through the people that
he invests in but he's a dentist full
time these are how most of the deals get
done is through these kinds of channels
you know the dentist won't have a
website to say I'm an angel investor
contact me how most deals happen are
through informal networks it's by
talking to people saying I'm looking for
an angel investor and here's what I'm
offering here's what my company is all
about you can look to people who are
connectors so lawyers accountants these
guys are connectors to investors so talk
to your lawyer talk to your account see
who they may know talk to your dentist
let him or her know what you're all
about the first angel investment
opportunity that I had was through my
dentist now he didn't invest but he put
me on to other angel investors as well
because they know each other and they
talk and so your best way to find these
angels is to start working your existing
network and it's not going to come from
your Uncle Joe right you know you don't
need him to invest that's more friends
and family round but they may have
contacts right you want to talk to all
of the lawyers all of their accountants
all of their doctors and all their
dentists talk to those people let them
know you're doing that's how the deals
get done it's through trusted networks
people referring each other to you and
so you gotta start planting the seeds
and spreading the word believe those you
watching liked the video give it a
thumbs up below let me know you think
leave a comment asked a question in the
comment section underneath and click on
my face to subscribe to the channel see
more videos like this thank you so much
I'll see you soon